the queen of Christmas has released a
new book just in time for the holidays
Mariah Carey is the Christmas princess
is a picture book that tells the story
of a little Mariah and how she survives
bullies with music I love that Carrie
says the book is not autobiographical
but a holiday-centered fairy tale okay
Gail got to talk to Carrie about her
love for Christmas and asked her if her
family shares the same Joy
do your kids like Christmas as much as
you do I asked them that question I said
and what was their answer I said do you
think you guys like Christmas more or I
like it more like who do you think likes
it more they said you they said I think
we can't choose they said it's I think
we love it the same which makes me
really happy because the last thing I
wanted to do was shove something down I
thought that they didn't like so we do a
lot of festive stuff we do roller
coasters we do you know things that are
so they love it too they love it too and
they and they love you know the other
times of the year that I try to make fun
things happen it's all about me giving
them what I really wanted which was just
to do all the things that the other kids
got to do and um so I just want them to
know that it's special
all right we were just hanging at
Mariah's house yes because she's got
twins her pre-tweens um Monroe and
Moroccan they they were there
um but she clearly loves this holiday we
talk about that we'll have the piece
next week next week but you hear that
music yeah senior broadcast producer
John Tower was like you were supposed to
tease that music at the top of your read
I did not so that's why we're playing it
because it's not Christmas do you feel
like it's Christmas season already no no
no I mean everybody's nodding now here's
a question like at what point should you
take your Halloween decorations down
because they're still up all over
exactly they should come down now I'm
still eating the candy